[Applause]
commit a loose ball foul by being overly
aggressive
on the offensive rebound sensor cindy
sarich
and ayton now that changes though
with that miss paul george
who just knocked down two clutch free
throws so reminiscent
of game two he had two big free throws
prior to missing those two
in the final seconds with eight seconds
remaining and now it's 6.3
here in game four
but you have to get a three on this
cousin's four for five from the line in
the series knocks that one down
just coming in in these final seconds
morris will come in
and now obviously he's going to miss the
second one just like paul george did on
purpose
and if you're phoenix how bad do you
want to go up 3-1
you have to get this rebound and that's
a violation i don't
presidents probably didn't know the rule
has to hit the rim violation that's
going to be phoenix ball
uh he's got to know the rule that's just
that's just a mishap
on behalf of demarcus cousins
so now phoenix will inbound with 5.8
they still have to get it in though ball
tip knock loose
paul has it and a whistle and a foul
against the clippers
chris paul lost his shoe in the mayhem
[Applause]
[Music]
and that could be that game saving
defensive rebound
paul did a great job again that's that's
so well executed
in terms of beginning the bounce just
hitting the rim and then george having
to grab chris paul
as paul george has fouled out
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what what a win for the phoenix suns
well with 1.3 remaining
if paul somehow missed the first and hit
the second and